we'll get set up now so then the next
week is a girl mounted essay from Oxford
are we talking about world water supply
infrastructure and he's replacing
Heloise who is here not because of not
appease a problem with a family issue
please healthily stepped in to cover it
so thank you as mentioned hilarious who
work tirelessly on this project left ear
lifted personal reasons so I just
stepped up to give you the overview of
the work it's trying to understand the
monitoring of hand pumps in in
sub-saharan Africa and a very simple
fact more than two hundred millions of
people in sub-sahara Africa depend on
hand pumps to get their daily water
usage and this hand pumps which could be
more than 1 million the unfortunately a
third of them is not working at any time
and worse as it takes usually more than
a month possibility to maintain those
hand pumps back into action because of
their mainly in rural areas with
infrastructure the transportation and
spare part limitations and the the
problem is what happens during this down
period and people since they mainly
depend on those hand pumps for water is
it they may go for alternatives and they
may expose themselves to contaminate
surface water where you may have
waterborne disease a very simple pilot
study done where they try to manually
call the corresponding person or
institution whenever hand pump breakdown
occurs showed that the maintenance
period can goes down I think as small as
a few days and with this we we have this
question what if we could predict the
failures and prevent any downtime and
giving this safely managed water is one
of the sustainable development for un so
our love which is computational health
informatics at the University of Oxford
focuses on trying to monitor patients
which actually is which is actually my
active area of research by using
variable sensors
we had also the experience to monitor
jet engines in aeroplanes and monitor to
monitor their well-being so we believe
this approach could be also mapped on
hand pumps as well for that on those pan
Pampas in rural areas we use the unknown
sight sensor device that contains a bit
of microprocessor processing unit and we
use the bond with the local telecom
network for any communication between
the device and remote server or cloud
server which works with the battery
however the the mostly the limitation is
when we try to send or transmitter
observation data with this limited
battery and in our telecom bandwidth
limitation it's very costly so the idea
is trying to do a bit of first initial
processing on that on the eighth device
itself and trying to transmit very
variable data would take all intelligent
data whenever there is a sense of
deterioration and then with that we
could have a cloud server remotely where
we could run more sophisticated
algorithms for more confident in France
so I think the overall health monitoring
system have few purchased the first one
is the rural infrastructure and sensor
node where you have concern pumps are
shown and this node mounted on one side
contains different sensors according
like accelerometer humidity and as I
said it works with the battery and the
type of sensor specifically used in the
study is the accelerometer sensor
mounted on hand pump trying to encode
the motion in three axis X Y Z and once
the data is collected we could transmit
to remote server using the telecom the
local telecom network but also it could
be downloaded manually on the PC I think
the most interesting part is the onboard
processing unit you have the Rob
servation
and we could do light novel filter
trying to detect with that the health
status of the hand pump and as I said
this involves trying to extra
very like time-frequency features of the
row times rest data and to use the
classification or inference using light
classifiers like logistic regression
I think the pipeline is as such you have
a data collection accelerometer data
with three channels and the
pre-processing steps will be trying to
visualize the frequency time
representation and as you see on
probably in the second column and they
it will have different a spectrogram
representation when the hand pump is
doing working normally and abnormally
and with the bit fine-tuning of the
features the third column on we do as I
said
lightweight novelty filter or
classification on the normality of the
hand pump so the feature is shown on the
left is when you have abnormal hand
pumping right on normal hand pump and
the I think the wells for this hand pump
could be as well deep and shallow and
mainly in rural areas where there are
spurs a ground water you need to go deep
down to get water so that is where the
challenge comes because as you see on
the distribution the normal and abnormal
seems to have very very similar because
with the deep hand pump I think the
infrastructure becomes more complex and
a device would be very a bit far away
from the water level and we focus on
that research so this is like the very
first validation where the data
collected on the site is manipulating
with the future extraction and initial
inferences turn with logistic regression
and as a baseline I think they did with
a sieve a massive baseline and as you
can see the logistic regression itself
could give very computer performance on
the edge itself this F 1 V 2 FF III are
the spectrogram frequence coefficient
features and it's the way they try to
sample features among like item 64
frequency coefficients to say more on
that aspect I think once they have the
time series data they apply of course
Fourier transform and they have like 64
coefficients but they try to discard the
motion related with the hand like no
level frequency
components so they tried to take the
frequency in bitten and this is
different selection of request
components I think like uniform sampling
random sampling among c64 Fresquez
coefficients so the overall idea is you
could do something better with logistic
regression on the side and finally we if
we know the status of the hand pump on
the on the side we could transfer data
with the hand pump is deteriorating and
on the cloud of course we could have the
luxury to run more sophisticated
algorithms to have more confident
decisions so as I said that is
transmitted only once the hand pump
suspect his condition is deteriorating
as I said earlier this reduced the cost
for transmitting data and of course
preserve battery life as well and as I
said the cloud system can apply more
computational power for machine learning
methods on top of the logistic
regression we did on the on the side the
this is the first result I think they
have type 2 type of data set one is
intra node where they have just one
deeper hand pump which which were to
more than eighteen fifty three meter
down where the intra note is like a bit
shallower but still dip with you into
industry and 53 metal tip so the overall
picture here is that on this I mean on
the cloud they tried different
classifiers like logistic random forest
and SVM the horizontal line shows how
much that ideally to transmit from the
side to the cloud so as you see ICBM
seems very dependent on the amount of
data you got whereas a random forest
seems very confident even if the amount
the proportion of data transmitted from
that on site is very limited so I think
from this they found out logistic
regression and run on on the side and
random forest on the cloud is a best
combination to get I think better
performance so how does this benefit
people using design the Pampas i think
the good thing it distributes the
computation was on the local and remote
that that will save a lot of
computational power and this
we like very advanced monitoring of
sound pompous in combination with
maintenance service can reduce and even
eliminate the eliminate the downtime if
proper proper monitoring is done so as I
said the early warning are most
preventive maintenance so I think here
is a group in case you wanna chat with
them thank you very much how much access
I think the question is like if it is a
rural area how could that die taxes
could be achieved I think we work in
collaboration with I think this is
particular in Kenya kawali region to be
specific so they collaborate with people
which work in the Geography Department
and other corresponding stakeholders in
Kenya and they use the local telecom
network to transmit like GCM the on-site
device has a GCM mode to transfer data
and I think the idea is like I think
they are very motivated with the pilot
study so when someone gives them a
number to care where the maintenance
fails it reduce the maintenance period
from M months to 3 days so rather than
just calling if we do like like
automatically using on-site device that
will replicate that that I think
reduction of the maintenance period
okay thanks Peter again all right and
thanks for stepping in for the missing